CASSIE KOZYRKOV: With over
300 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
"How to Do Predictive
Analytics in BigQuery,"
then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
You can now do machine
learning right in BigQuery.
And you're about to see
what that looks like.
But first, what's
all the fuss about?
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
enterprise-class data
warehouse.
If you have petabytes of data,
you can analyze all of it
with a single query
in standard SQL.
And you can even do
real-time analytics.
The best part is that BigQuery
is serverless and fully
managed, which means that
all you need to think about
is what data you have and
how you want to analyze it.
Machine learning is an
algorithmic approach
to making repeated
decisions with data.
And it's incredibly useful.
It lets you automate
whole new classes of tasks
and create business
critical prediction systems.
To make machine learning work,
you need data and algorithms.
Putting them together gives you
models for making predictions.
So if you were waiting for
the catch, there it is.
This little thing
about putting them
together can actually be
much harder than it sounds.
Data fuels machine learning.
It's what makes
machine learning tick.
And you have it in BigQuery.
Now you've got to get your data
into machine learning software.
And your data set is not small.
How do you get a copy
of your whole beast
of a multi-petabyte data
set into TensorFlow in order
to get that sophisticated
model you're after?
Now you're back to thinking
about infrastructure at scale
again, which is
what you were trying
to avoid in the first place.
So instead of bringing your
data to machine learning,
you can help bring machine
learning to your data
right in BigQuery.
That's what BigQuery
ML is all about.
And it supports linear
and logistic regression.
So that means forecasting and
classification just got easy.
Here's what housing
prediction looks like.
And as an added bonus, you
get those model evaluation
functions you know and love,
including the ROC curve.
What you're looking at here
is the Data Studio version.
We've got Looker
integration, too,
making it easy to
explore data, create
models, and operationalize
your ML workflow with Looker.
BigQuery ML means that
machine learning at scale
is no longer just for huge teams
of data scientists and data
engineers.
And the possibilities
are endless.
There are so many
applications just
waiting for you to dive in.
In the full talk, you'll get
inspired by alpha customer use
cases.
And you'll hear
directly from Hearst
as they tell their
BigQuery ML story.
And of course, you'll get
to see BigQuery ML in action
in the live demo.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]